I don't know if you've all been keeping
up with sports but I don't think it to
be a sports fan to hear about yeah Cory
it's just amazing in the NBA
there was a gentleman on the New York
Knicks named Jeremy Lin everybody's
talking about John
yeah he's the NBA's first American
Taiwanese player he has single-handedly
taken over the NBA with his high scoring
his tenacious defense and his humble
lifestyle people are very excited about
him well here to comment more on this
new phenomenon is one of our writers mr.
Deon Cole Deon thanks Conan yeah I knew
all the hype surrounding Asian
basketball player Jeremy Lin and quite
frankly it makes me nervous
and I tell you why but first let me do
my I'm about to say something racist
look around
I'm nervous because I don't want agents
taking over basketball like they took
over hip-hop dancing oh that hurts but I
guess we hurt Asians as well when we
made up a rap group called wu-tang clan
so let's just call it even Asian people
I love like people keep basketball okay
and you can take over any other jobs we
have like being preachers bodyguards to
celebrities
or simply working at the DMV so please
let black people keep basketball thank
you very much he on Carl
ladies and gentlemen very well said